Real machines have memory hierarchies.
That means, that between a processor and
a primary storage device like a disk,
there are layers of memory in between.
And as you get closer to the processor,
those memories get faster but
also smaller.
Now the difference in all of the size,
latency, and
bandwidth between successive levels,
might be an order of magnitude.
Unfortunately, our usual model of
an algorithm doesn't distinguish
between the size and
speed of these different memories.
Yet, if you want to achieve high
performance, and you know you do, then
you need to design your algorithms to
take advantage of the memory hierarchy.
Now, sometimes the hardware or operating
system can manage these memories for
you, automatically.
But using these memories
optimally is hard.
So try as they might,
these automatic schemes can't
completely solve the problem for you.
And that means the onus is on you
to work your algorithmic magic.
This lesson is designed
to help you get started.